hey guys it is the 8th of june and my
name is Jessa McDowell back bringing me
the new things although this time from
our San Francisco office that's a little
weird but I do have some pretty sweet
stories including one awesome public
tantrum so we should settle in nicely
German filmmaker and we're not of a
worse career achievement razzies of wood
Hoover Bowl has blown off the handle
today about crowdfunding and it's well
worth the watch if you're after a little
crazy a lot of crazy having created
films such as House of the Dead alone in
the dark postal and blood rain fall is
well known for taking cool video games
and turning them into movies that are
well a bit [ __ ] really he's currently
running a kickstarter to try and raise
money to make the third installment in
his rampage film series in a youtube
video entitled [ __ ] you all he explains
that this is his third campaign says
crowdfunding is quote absolutely dead
antwort nobody gives a [ __ ] he also says
a whole bunch of things that i can't
repeat here and rounds off his rant with
quote i have enough money to play golf
till I'm dead you can catch both this
tirade and his subsequent blowout over
the Hollywood industry in our story on
gamespot a bunch of horses fix details
have leaked today so here's all the
sweet info for you racing game fans as
uncovered by IGN you screenshots from
the game which features sexy cars have
leaked onto the official Japanese Xbox
website along with new details
reportedly the game will have over 460
cars and promises cooked breath-taking
graphics the images show off for two
sixes rain effects and nighttime driving
the league also suggests there will be
two players split-screen 24 player
online races 26 world famous locations
and support for the still ridiculous
renamed drivatar it may not have been
your favorite game of the year but
apparently the order 1886 ever doing too
badly when it comes to sales figures
critics may not have loved it but ready
at Dawn's ps4 exclusive may have done
quite a bit better come
Russia Lee if recent comments from the
developer are to be believed near idiot
door CEO Paul sands told game informer
that while they can't divulge the
specific sales numbers they were quote
well on their way to achieving the sales
performance that we thought it was
announced today that stamp would be
replacing rue weerasuriya as see you all
ready at dawn let me know down in the
comments what you cared about today and
be sure to head to gain lots of stories
on what a great blood foreign players
who hated schita is and the witcher 3
continuing to smash sales charts that's
everything I've got for you today but
i'll have more gaming news stories
tomorrow so be sure to check back with
me then